amis téléspectateurs bonjour vous êtes
sur le plateau dès maintenant l'émission
qui revient avec plaisir avec vous sur
l'actualité politique de la semaine vous
connaissez le principe hashtag et
maintenant si vous souhaitez réagir sur
ce plateau aujourd'hui on a du talent de
la fougue de l'expérience et du charme
oui Pascal perrineo est là bonjour
bonjour comment allez-vous cher Pascal
vous êtes professeur des universités
Sciences Po Paris je renvoie à votre
dernier livre le populisme c'est à
retrouver au pif valérie lecable est
également avec nous bonjour bonjour ça
va vous êtes présidente de l'agence HK
stratégie et le charme est là Jonathan
ou l'expérience
bonjour vous êtes éditorialiste
politique à Libération ravi de vous
accueillir sur ce plateau et Juliette
Medel est également avec nous bonjour
bonjour vous êtes ancienne ministre ravi
de vous avoir avec nous dans cette
émission on se demandera ce qu'être de
gauche je veux encore dire après une
nouvelle semaine de cacophonie à la
nupesse on se demandera ce que Marine Le
Pen tente de nous dire quand à l'annonce
en 2023 sa candidature pour 202 on verra
si le gouvernement a encore des idées
pour améliorer notre pouvoir d'achat et
puis on se penchera sur la relation
d'amour entre Sarko et Hollande nouvel
épisode de cette idylle cette semaine
vous verrez mais d'abord merci président
Larcher l'Europe et la France face aux
défis de l'immigration la semaine
dernière près de 12000 personnes ont
débarquées en quelques jours sur
l'italienne de Lampedusa dont la foulée
Gérald Darmanin s'est rendu à Rome il a
proposé à l'Italie l'aide de la France
en matière de contrôle des frontières le
ministre de l'intérieur c'est voulu très
ferme sur la question écoutez-le France
accueillera pas de migrants qui viennent
de l'anpe12 à la France veut une
position de fermeté il y a une
immigration irrégulière en Europe en
France et en Italie qu'il faut combattre
et c'est pas en accueillant plus de
personnes qu'on va tarir un flux qui
évidemment touche nos capacités
d'intégration si les personnes sont
éligibles à l'asile elles sont
persécutées sexuellement politiquement
religieusement évidemment c'est le
devoir de la France comme d'autres pays
européens de les accueillir il y a
beaucoup évidemment on le comprend
Pascal vous comprenez cette ligne de
fermeture de la part du gouvernement de
la part de Gérald Darmanin sur cette
question oui on peut comprendre des fois
avoir un discours cohérent vous voyez
déjà quand on écoute le ministre de
l'Intérieur la position de principe pour
satisfaire les tendances les plus fortes
de l'opinion c'est de dire pas un
immigrant clandestin ne franchira la
frontière et ne sera accueilli en France
et puis quelques mots après sauf voilà
si tel ou tel individu correspond voilà
aux critères de de l'asile politique
donc je crois que le Gouvernement sur ce
sujet hautement inflammable devrait
pratiquer un discours qui ne flatte pas
dans le sens du poil les tendances les
plus binaires sur ce sujet et Dieu sait
si c'est un aussi bien à gauche qu'à
droite c'est un sujet sur lequel il y a
une certaine binarité un peu primaire
qui s'exprime les tendances binaires
c'est quoi ils flatte électorat de
droites Jonathan c'est ça ce que dit
Pascal
à j'ai compris que c'était binaire des
deux côtés mais c'était le sentiment que
Gérald Darmanin ça s'adresse d'abord à
un côté non mais c'est typiquement le
genre de sujet qui est qui est très
complexe et qui est très difficile pour
un responsable politique à résumé par
par des formules je pense qu'il y a un
principe de responsabilité d'assumer la
complexité du sujet et on voit qu'il y a
un discours qui échangeant selon les
circonstances évidemment quand on est
face à aux images de Lampedusa c'est
compliqué en fait d'arriver à remettre
un peu de rationalité face à des images
qui suscitent de l'émotion et beaucoup
d'instrumentalisation sujet d'opinion
évidemment compliqué c'est ça j'ai pas
de nier que le il y a un enjeu autour de
l'immigration que ça fait aussi des
années qu'on contient des discours qui
sont pas forcément très responsables ce
que je constate c'est qu'il y a quand
même une mélodonisation des esprits
c'est à cause de Georgia Meloni a été
élu en Italie sur ce sujet il y avait
une forme d'unanimisme chef du
gouvernement italien il y avait une
forme d'un animisme dans la classe
politique française en tout cas chez les
macronistes comme à gauche d'une manière
générale pour dire c'est le post
fascisme qui arrive on a rien à voir
avec ces valeurs il y a elle il y a nous
et on est là pour pour proposer autre
chose et on se rend compte que quand il
s'agit d'être confronté de façon très
concrète à une situation on est quand
même dans cette idée de d'Europe
forteresse qui est un fantasme donc
qu'une Europe soit une Europe
responsable qui gère ces flux
migratoires c'est quelque chose qu'on
peut entendre en revanche l'idée de dire
qui suffit d'être martial pour régler le
sujet personne n'y croit melonisation
des esprits nous dit Jonathan vous êtes
d'accord Valérie quand vous entendez
géraldar maintenant qu'est-ce que ça
vous inspire ça m'inspire que sa
position à lui et qui fait cavalier un
petit peu seul parce que si vous écoutez
du gouvernement non c'est pas du tout
mais pour moi pas du tout non pour moi
c'est pas la position du gouvernement
pour deux raisons parce que quand
Emmanuel Macron va rencontrer Georgia
Meloni pour parler de Lampedusa il
revient avec le mot le plus fort qui
était la solidarité nous ne laisserons
pas tomber l'Italie il y aura un
principe de solidarité et que le
lendemain de l'intervention de Gérald
Darmanin sur France Inter Stéphane
séjourné qui est comme vous le savez le
patron de renaissance et très proche du
chef de l'État pour moi recadre Darmanin
moins de 10 ans il y aura la solidarité
il y aura l'agile ce que ne démant pas
Darmanin sauf que lui il insiste sur la
sur la fermeté donc moi ce que je vois
dans la posture de Gérald Darmanin c'est
effectivement d'aller flatter l'opinion
qui considère qu'il y a trop
d'émulations en France maintenant
majoritairement au-delà de 60 % je crois
et mais le discours global du
gouvernement et beaucoup plus nuancée et
les autres et l'imposition du chef
d'État selon moi et de ce que j'en ai
compris est plutôt de conserver le
principe de solidarité et en cela
Darmanin une fois de plus s'oppose à la
position du chef de l'État et joue sa
propre partition la suite et pour la
présidentielle de 200 questions un peu
binaire malheureusement on est
accueillir ces migrants mais attendez
il y a un principe de droit le principe
de droit qui s'applique c'est le
règlement Dublin faisons un tout petit
peu de technique juridique le règlement
Dublin c'est que quand un immigré arrive
sur le sol de l'un des pays européens
c'est le pays européen qui a la
responsabilité d'examiner sa situation
et ensuite normalement normalement les
pays d'Europe doivent se partager les
migrants qui arrivent et donc la France
en fait doit prendre sa part
la France doit prendre sa part sauf que
on est aujourd'hui exactement dans la
même situation qu'en 2019 au moment des
précédentes élections européennes la
situation n'a pas changé c'est à dire
que l'Europe ne maîtrise toujours pas
ses frontières et c'est à dire qu'il y a
toujours pas d'accord entre les pays
européens pour se répartir la charge
d'une émigration avec une population qui
pour une grande partie Est de l'asile
mais de l'asile politique mais aussi des
situations de misère extrême donc oui la
France doit prendre sa part mais que ce
qui se joue aujourd'hui le ministre de
l'Intérieur tient un discours de
politique intérieure
marqué par des forces enjeux électoraux
notamment le projet de loi immigration
qui va être examiné à l'Assemblée et
pour l'approbation duquel il a besoin de
la droite et le président de la
République applique la législation
européenne étant tente de trouver une
solution à un problématique qui n'en a
toujours pas trouvé
ces chiffres avec ce que pensent les
Français de justement cette de ces
migrants qui arrivent sur l'île de
l'empelusa pour 65% des Français la
France ne doit pas accueillir les
migrants de lampedusale et de raison les
plus évoquées par les sondés sont le
manque de moyens économique et la menace
pour notre
identité et notre culture Pascale
comment vous interprétez ces chiffres si
vous voulez ça ne varie pas c'est une
constante de l'opinion publique environ
deux tiers des Français considèrent en
effet qu'il y a trop d'immigrations et
cette perception est nourrie par deux
inquiétudes une inquiétude économique et
sociale dans un contexte où pour la
majorité des Français la France n'a plus
les moyens comme
un premier ministre socialiste
d'accueillir toute la misère du monde
Michel
je crois pour les Français il y a cet
aspect là voilà la France n'a pas les
moyens de gérer il suffit d'aller dans
les départements dans les départements
qui jouent les régions de forte
immigration comme les Alpes-Maritimes et
de voir par exemple la manière dont les
pouvoirs publics sont complètement
débordés par l'aide accordée aux
immigrants mineurs et puis il y a le
second élément ce que l'on a appelé
l'insécurité culturelle c'est-à-dire
pour nombre de Français en effet une
immigration trop importante créée des
foyers d'insécurité culturelle
d'identification
sur l'identité si vous voulez de la
société française que nous constituons
est-ce que une immigration à haute dose
dans certains territoires par exemple
comme la Seine-Saint-Denis par exemple
comme certaines commun des
Alpes-Maritimes n'engendrent pas un
trouble sur la manière de vivre ensemble
Jonathan est-ce qu'on peut faire contre
la volonté de la population de la
majorité de la population qui nous dit
on a beau être humaniste on n'a pas
forcément envie de les voir venir chez
nous c'est ce qu'on peut comprendre
on paye une très mauvaise façon de poser
ces sujets ou un manque de courage
politique sur ces sujets depuis
longtemps donc après l'opinion c'est
évidemment quelque chose qu'il faut
prendre en compte on peut difficilement
gouverner en toute circonstances contre
les Français on peut pas dire que la
réforme des retraites n'aurait pas dû
être appliquée tel quel alors que les
Français étaient contre et puis faire
fier de l'opinion des Français quand
elle nous arrange pas donc il faut le
prendre en compte dans la problématique
mais ce que décrivait Pascal Perrineau
c'est une inconséquence de la gestion de
ces sujets là c'est à dire que ce soit
un seul sujet pour les pour les zones
limitrophes c'est un problème ça vaut
pour les Alpes-Maritimes à proximité de
l'Italie ça vaut pour l'Italie en
première ligne ou la Grèce dans
l'accueil parce que géographiquement
c'est là où ça se passe encore une fois
il y a que des réponses nationales de
temps en temps on a un petit sursaut
pour dire évidemment que la réponse doit
être européenne c'est pas vrai la
réponse elle est pas européenne on le
voit depuis
15 crises postes Siri avec l'arrivée
d'un certain nombre de migrants on a vu
que d'un pays à l'autre c'était le
courage politique des responsables il y
a l'Allemagne d'un côté pour des besoins
aussi économiques ça c'est souvent le
non-dit quand on est sur le débat
purement national en France on a les
bons et les mauvais migrants
c'est-à-dire ceux qui bossent déjà
précisément tout en étant en situation
irrégulière tout le monde est d'accord
pour les régulariser quasiment
aujourd'hui et ça marche et ça va se
faire écouter Benoît Hamon Benoît Hamon
qui pointe du doigt la différence
précisément de traitement selon les
populations qui arrivent chez nous
écouter le on est capable aujourd'hui de
réaliser l'inclusion et les associations
ayant contribué de 4 millions
d'Ukrainiens et on peut pas le faire
pour 10000 personnes qui viennent
d'Afrique du Nord ou d'Afrique
subsaharienne qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
je veux dire en France il y a eu 100 000
Ukrainiens qui sont venus il y en a-t-il
un seul qui dort dehors non pourquoi
parce qu'on les a autorisés à travailler
on leur a permis d'apprendre la langue
française rapidement et on les a logé
parmi ceux qui viennent chez nous
oui il y a clairement
poussé d'ailleurs par le rassemblement
national enfin disons et même par une
certaine droite il y a clairement une
discrimination à l'endroit des musulmans
enfin faut quand même le dire en tout
cas dans les discours qui sont qui sont
qui sont proférés donc oui il faut être
vigilant pour ça mais moi j'en reviens
encore une fois pardon mais à
l'application du droit je vois pas ou
non de quoi on dirait aujourd'hui qu'on
ne doit pas encore une fois prendre
notre part de cette asile politique mais
c'est du reste ce que dit aussi le
ministre de l'Intérieur dans un exercice
en effet de de
duplicités vous êtes les bienvenus les
autres ont bien un peu on sélectionne
[Musique]
proposons de nos anciennes colonies de
notre présence en Afrique en Afrique du
Nord etc nous avons une sociologie
d'immigration qui n'est pas la même par
exemple que celle de l'Allemagne qui a
plus de populations turques etc et
l'insécurité culturelle d'en parler
Pascal tout à l'heure joue forcément
c'est vrai que le cumul de personnes
d'origine du même continent crée on va
pas se cacher derrière son petit doigt
créer une situation sur laquelle il y a
ce type de comportement qui était
Saint-Denis c'est aussi une politique
publique qui a créé des ghettos et on
sait très bien que ça ça crée évidemment
les chiffres quoi les chiffres sont
importants c'est juste objectivement
qu'on a concentré dans les mêmes
endroits à des populations c'est aussi
une réalité si après on entretien
je rappelle que pour le peu que la
France on a pris les migrants qu'on a
accueilli après la crise en Syrie à
l'époque on a fait un milliard de
reportages les uns et les autres pour
raconter à quel point ça s'était soit
mieux passé que ce qui avait été raconté
encore une fois un peu de courage sur
ces questions là ne feraient pas de mal
gouvernement en fait il a assez pour
notre pouvoir d'achat ce qui est certain
c'est que les prix de l'alimentation ont
explosé ces derniers mois l'exécutif
multiplie les réunions avec les
industriels et les distributeurs pour
tenter d'enrayer la hausse il a
d'ailleurs fait une nouvelle proposition
cette semaine l'autorisation de la vente
à perte pour les carburants le problème
c'est que pour l'instant personne n'en
veut écouter
globalement notre méthode c'est
d'engager tout le monde dans cette lutte
contre l'inflation l'État peut pas
porter à lui seul le coût de l'inflation
sinon ça va creuser des déficits la
démarche est louable du gouvernement
mesure exceptionnelle contexte
exceptionnel mais la réalité économique
c'est que en fait on aura on va pas
l'utiliser cette cette possibilité là
parce qu'à un moment si on fait ça on va
augmenter le prix des pâtes donc on
n'est pas complètement cinglé en ce qui
nous concerne nous ou groupe Carrefour
nous n'a puisque nous ne pouvons pas
nous concerter vous le savez nous
n'avons pas vocation et nous n'avons pas
nous ne non pas à perte nous
continuerons à faire des opérations à
prix coûtant
l'improvisation totale cette histoire de
la vente à perte visiblement oui c'est
du bricolage et de l'improvisation il
semblerait normalement quand on prend ce
genre de décision qui déjà pose question
sur le plan économique on essaye de
trouver des assurances auprès des
acteurs qui vont être concernés
visiblement les les patrons de la grande
distribution ont été prévenus une
demi-heure une heure avant et une
demi-heure une heure après ils ont
commencé à dire que ça serait sans eux
c'est vrai qu'en termes de messages de
la puissance publique s'implique et
créative trouve des nouvelles solutions
alors qu'on a sonné la fin du quoi qu'il
en coûte alors qu'on sent que sur
l'usage de l'argent public il y a il y a
une envie de de fermer un peu les
écoutilles là ça donne un sentiment
d'insécurité collective en se disant
qu'est-ce que c'est que ces amateurs et
ça m'amène à cette question charges
Jonathan le gouvernement fait-il assez
pour le pouvoir d'achat des Français en
fait il est assez pour notre pouvoir
d'achat de invités sur ce plateau ne
sont pas du tout d'accord d'un côté on
retrouve Pascal de l'autre Juliette
c'est un duel les amis vous savez
comment ça marche 45 secondes pour
dérouler vos arguments allez on va
commencer avec vous Pascal vous allez
nous dire pourquoi selon vous oui le
gouvernement bah il fait ce qu'il peut
sur le pour le pouvoir d'achat oui il
fait ce qu'il peut il a énormément
investi en effet lors de la période de
la covid il a continué dans la période
postérieure et il continue par exemple
sur le terrain des du prix de
l'électricité à engager un effort
budgétaire qui est un effort extrêmement
important et je crois que la solution
tout est dans la manière de la solution
est maintenant d'associer les acteurs
privés à la lutte contre l'inflation et
c'est vrai que la manière dont le
gouvernement borne s'y est pris et
déplorable parce que c'est marqué au
coin d'un amateurisme qui mène dans
l'histoire de l'action publique sous la
Cinquième République est rare
bravo vous avez presque respecté votre
temps bravo cher Pascal Juliette 45
secondes vous allez me dire pourquoi
vous n'êtes pas du tout d'accord avec
Pascal je pense que ils font beaucoup il
s'agit dans tous les sens il dépense
beaucoup d'argent public d'ailleurs avec
un gros péril sur l'équilibre de nos
budgets mais ils font mal moi un je ne
crois pas du tout à l'auto régulation
donc dire au secteur de la grande
distribution je lève l'interdiction
devant ta perte et puis débrouillez-vous
ça peut pas marcher deuxièmement je
crois beaucoup plus en fait à la
contrainte et je crois beaucoup plus que
la baisse de la TVA qui serait partagée
entre la grande distribution tous les
secteurs de la distribution des sens et
l'État une mesure législative claire et
nette qui traiterait tout le monde de la
même manière et deuxième sujet il faut
augmenter les salaires donc sans
remettre à la négociation salariale à
mon avis ça suffira pas et un petit coup
de pouce législatif voire réglementaire
sur l'augmentation des salaires très
nécessaire
du côté de votre voisin vous êtes
d'accord il y a un côté amateur du côté
du gouvernement je suis complètement
d'accord mais ce qui se passe là est
beaucoup plus grave c'est-à-dire que en
fait ils ont distribué l'échec à tout va
alors ça a commencé avec le covid mais
ils ont continué comme parce qu'elle a
dit avec l'électricité le carburant etc
et là ils sont dans une impasse
absolument terrible parce que bien sûr
qu'il faudrait baisser l'État mais le
problème c'est que le déficit français
est devenu tellement important la dette
est tellement élevée et les taux
d'intérêt remontent il n'en ont juste
plus les moyens ce ne serait pas
possible de dire on va pas aller non
plus à banqueroute donc en fait ils ont
donné l'argent vides ils ont ils ont
distribué
l'argenté l'argent quand ça allait bien
et maintenant que ça va mal les caisses
sont vides c'est à dire qu'on est dans
un effet de ciseaux qui est extrêmement
dangereux parce que d'un côté l'État est
devenu impuissant il n'a plus aucune
marge de manœuvre financière et de
l'autre côté et bien les gens n'arrivent
plus à financer effectivement quand à la
hausse des salaires c'est la guerre dans
les entreprises et c'est pas la scène
n'arrive plus à joindre les deux bouts
je vais vous montrer cette enquête
jamais les Français n'ont eu autant de
mal à boucler les fins de mois ils
auraient besoin de 588 euros net de plus
chaque mois pour vivre confortablement
c'est une estimation de du baromètre CSA
pour Cofidis c'est un record depuis 12
ans est-ce que la classe politique
jonathan est prend la mesure de ce qui
est en train de se passer oui je pense
que globalement ils prennent la mesure
après encore une fois ça oblige à
changer un certain nombre de paradigmes
moi je suis tout à fait d'accord que il
faut que l'État assume un certain nombre
de contraintes ça vaut pour les
questions sociales comme ça ça vaut on
en parle pas cette fois-ci mais sur les
questions écologiques il y a quand on
s'affirme comme étant la puissance
publique il faut la démontrer cette
puissance et si on n'a pas les moyens
financiers ce qui peut tout à fait
s'entendre même si après tout ça est
aussi une histoire de choix de priorité
il y a un rôle à jouer de régulateur qui
contraint un certain nombre d'acteurs
un quand on utilise le chéquier il faut
cibler les aides pour ceux qui en ont
besoin soit sur la question des
carburants on a vu on est un 4x4 en
étant un cadre supérieur on était encore
plus subventionnés par l'État que si on
avait une petite voiture et qu'on était
au SMIC donc ça il y a comme un problème
de ciblage donc on est toujours usine à
gaz c'est compliqué bah si c'est
compliqué il faut prendre le temps de le
faire mais on peut pas distribuer sans
que sans la moindre idée de cibler les
gens dans la qui en ont besoin et après
dire bah on a plus les moyens alors que
la crise s'installe et encore une fois
quand on dit il y a plus d'argent ça
dépend où il y a un certain nombre
d'acteurs que ce soit dans le monde de
l'énergie ou que ce soit chez les
industriels de l'agroalimentaire ou les
marges n'ont jamais été aussi importante
ou les profits s'accumulent il faut
trouver le moyen de mobiliser cet argent
cet argent il vient pas ce sont des
Français sont des Français qui se
sacrifient en termes de soins en termes
de repas sauté en termes de que dans les
banques alimentaires voilà encore une
fois on peut toujours avoir la petite
larme à l'oeil au moment faut se
retrousser les manches et bouger et
pourquoi on augmente pas les salaires
Pascal
l'augmentation des salaires
indépendamment pour la masse en effet
des fonctionnaires ça ne dépend pas de
l'état ça ne dépend pas de l'état il
faut quand même que les Françaises dans
la tête ça dépend de la négociation
sociale entre les actes il y a des
façons de d'encourager de stimuler la
négociation de fixer même des objectifs
l'État peut parfaitement s'investir dans
la négociation et par ailleurs de
l'autre côté il peut aussi négocier avec
les grosses entreprises le carnet de
chèques sur les comptes de l'État ça
suffit mais considérer que les grosses
entreprises qui pour certaines sont des
profiteurs de guerre devraient
contribuer davantage à soutenir le
pouvoir d'achat ça ça pourrait faire
l'objet d'une mesure
il faut bien se dire d'abord les n'ayons
pas une vision misérabiliste de ce qui
se passe les négociations sociales il y
en a des tas et il y a des entreprises
où il y a en effet des négociations et
des hausses de salaire quand on regarde
pour cent en moyenne et quand on regarde
l'évolution du pouvoir d'achat en France
par rapport à nos voisins européens elle
est loin d'être la plus catastrophique
loin
de la difficulté c'est le genre de sujet
c'est le genre de sujet ou quand on a du
mal à faire ses courses on se compare
pas aux Allemands
de dire que c'est pas l'augment l'État
qui augmente le salaire c'est d'une
évidence absolue on souffre dans ce pays
d'un manque de puissance des
organisations sociales des syndicats à
l'intérieur de l'entreprise je veux dire
les grandes étapes
facilement Valérie en plus
j'ai pas interdit allez-y explique non
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que
l'époque je veux dire il y a eu la grève
sur les retraites on n'a pas eu de grève
sur les augmentations de salaire il faut
créer un rapport de force qui soit
favorable dans les entreprises on va on
peut pas dire juste Yaka et faucon parce
que les enfants
ce sont les entreprises qui payent les
gens en dehors du secteur public et les
entreprises elles font exactement ce
qu'elles veulent dans ce pays parce que
il y a pas il y a aucun contre-pouvoir
plutôt grandes entreprises et les et
donc les grosses parlantes total par
exemple qui a mis son essence à 99 euros
dans les stations-service c'est des
mesures qui sont positives ça il faut
quand même
c'est important
si vous vous en remettez au bon vouloir
à la bonne je vais terminer si vous vous
en remettez bon vouloir terminer ce côté
donc allez-y moi je ne crois pas dans
l'auto régulation c'est-à-dire que je ne
crois pas du pouvoir aux grands
distributeur et en disant aux grands
distributeur au secteur de
l'agroalimentaire débrouillez-vous tout
seul débrouillez-vous tout seul on
compte sur vous pour que de votre bonne
volonté vous baissier laissez la
terminer
allez-y Juliette juste allez-y je ne
crois pas dans l'autorégulation et je
pense que l'État doit s'investir de
façon ferme et claire éventuellement en
taxant les secteurs les plus profitables
car il y a des profiteurs de guerre je
le redis l'inflation aujourd'hui sur le
[Musique]
crédibilité auprès des Français cette
semaine elle a annoncé qu'en 2027 bah
faudra compter sur elle écoutait là
l'instant tant que j'en ai pas décidé
autrement je suis la candidate naturelle
de mon Coran la présidentielle Jonathan
pourquoi cette annonce pourquoi
maintenant moi je trouve ça tout je
pense que c'est pas faux sur le fond
quelle est la candidate naturelle je
trouve ça toujours symptomatique quand
on est obligé de le réaffirmer ça montre
quand même qu'on a pas grand chose
d'autre à dire moi je trouve que c'est
une crédibilité qui se construit quand
même beaucoup par par le silence et par
la vacuité ou les ou les erreurs
stratégiques de ces de ces adversaires
je suis pas sûr que quand on sera
recontrondé un contexte de campagne
présidentielle elle aura vraiment
progressé elle aura vraiment travaillé
par rapport au foie précédente donc je
trouve que c'est oui ça ça mange pas de
pain de venir dire je suis la candidate
naturel en l'état encore une fois je
pense que ce qui doit interroger c'est
pourquoi elle sent
l'urgence ou l'importance de devoir le
réaffirmer très d'un Français sur deux
c'est l'Institut élève qui nous dit ça
cette semaine près d'un Français sur
deux estime que Marine Le Pen elle est
qualité nécessaire pour être président
de la République elle est vue comme
capable de rassembler les Français par
47% de la population c'est plus neuf
fois par rapport au mois de juin elle a
les qualités nécessaires pour être
présidente pour 48% des sondés on
rappelle qu'elle a fait 41,5 % à la
dernière présidentielle Pascale il y a
quelque chose qui est en train de
changer dans le regard qu'on porte sur
Marine Le Pen qui est en train d'évoluer
si vous voulez la lente mais régulière
stratégie de respectabilisation comme on
dit de Marine Le Pen qui aurait pu
échouer n'échoue pas
c'est à dire que l'amélioration
régulière de l'image de Marine Le Pen
attention sur l'ensemble de ce que l'on
attend d'une femme publique c'est-à-dire
les sujets régaliens même les sujets
maintenant politique étrangères les
sujets politiques économiques et
sociales sur tous ces fondamentaux son
image s'améliore c'est à dire que bien
sûr dans la perspective extrêmement
lointaine pour l'instant d'une
présidentielle
elle fait partie véritablement
maintenant euh
des aller de la poignée de celles et
ceux qui sont tout à fait capables de
l'emporter dans un second tour
d'ailleurs il faut être si vous quittons
les sondages regardons ce qui s'était
passé au dernier législatives dans les
seconds tours avec les candidats du RN
c'était absolument frappant en 2017 le
RN n'arrivait pas à peser dans un
scrutin où il s'affrontait à la droite
ou à la gauche là dans 50% des cas ils
l'ont apporté donc ça prouve ça y est
que même avec le scrutin majoritaire à
deux tours le RN est bien sûr Marine Le
Pen acquiert peu à peu une vocation
majoritaire et c'est peut-être plus
c'est peut-être la fin du vote
protestataire c'est peut-être un autre
une autre un autre vote peut-être
Valérie c'est ça je pense que elle
bénéficie de son attitude de l'attitude
de son groupe de ces 89 députés à
l'Assemblée nationale depuis les
dernières législatives je pense que la
posture extrêmement agressive et
bruyante de LFI n'a pas profité à
Jean-Luc Mélenchon mais
l'absence de colère visible du
rassemblement national lui donne un côté
plus responsable et plus apte à
gouverner après moi la question que je
me pose c'est ce que c'est Marine Le Pen
ou est-ce que c'est le rassemblement
national parce que en fait Marine Le Pen
à part avec cette phrase on ne l'entend
pas elle est très absente elle parle pas
beaucoup elle a une stratégie de
communication d'être assez peu visible
et du coup vous avez dit il y a encore
trois ans est-ce que les défauts et les
imperfections enfin le manque de
puissance présidentielle qu'elle a
montré pendant les derniers scrutins ne
va pas l'empêcher finalement elle
personnellement cette petite nuance que
j'aimerais apporter
sur deux considèrent que Marine Le Pen
est d'extrême droite ses 49% des
Français ça veut dire qu'il y a même des
on perçoit encore Marine Le Pen comme
alors pas forcément enfin toujours dans
le spectre politique mais toujours à
l'extrême du ce spectre politique et à
l'extrême droite oui parce que dans
Marine Le Pen il y a Le Pen donc tout le
monde sait très bien quel est son père
quel est son histoire alors elle elle
tient pas aujourd'hui des propos
d'extrême droite parce que sinon elle
aurait été condamné par la justice mais
on sait très bien qu'il entoure on sait
très bien d'où elle vient et qu'elles
ont été à quoi elle a été bibronnée donc
ça c'est un premier point mais le
deuxième point sur le fait qu'elle monte
constamment dans les sondages suffit de
regarder les résultats des élections
législatives de 2022 pour voir que toute
une série de bastions de la gauche ont
été pris et pris au la main par le
rassemblement national ça dit quoi ça
dit aussi que sur le fond aujourd'hui
personne ne réussit et pas les parties
de gouvernement et là c'est ni la gauche
ni la droite traditionnelle personne ne
réussit à résoudre les problématiques de
fond c'est à dire la question
identitaire la question de la puissance
publique la question de la légitimité
des processus démocratiques tous ces
sujets pourtant majeurs sur lesquels
nous sommes beaucoup à avoir échoué on
parle beaucoup de 2027 et pour 2027 on
parle beaucoup dans certains Jordan
Bardella qui a pris la parole cette
semaine il assure que lui ne trahira pas
sa patronne écouter le
je ne serai pas les manuels Macron de
François Hollande et je ne serai pas
d'Emmanuel Macron de Marine Le Pen pour
une raison très simple c'est que
celui qui pense pouvoir
nous opposer avec Marine Le Pen n'est
pas né nous avons une relation de
confiance qui est très forte bon ça vous
allez me dire ce que vous en pensez
Jordan Bardelet est-il le principal
concurrent de Marine Le Pen sur la route
de 2027 des invités sur ce plateau ne
sont pas du tout d'accord c'est un duel
45 secondes chacun d'un côté Valérie de
l'autre Jonathan vous allez commencer
Valérie vous allez me dire pourquoi
selon vous oui celui qu'on vient de voir
à l'écran bah c'est peut-être le
principal concurrent de Marine Le Pen
alors son grand handicap c'est qu'en
2027 il n'aura qu'à peine 32 ans ce qui
est pas beaucoup c'est très jeune mais
il a il a une expérience qui augmente
très très rapidement il a une puissance
médiatique Marine Le Pen n'a jamais
acquis et les bons il a raison de dire
ça maintenant et bien sûr que il peut
pas dire autre chose simplement si elle
aurait de sa troisième candidature en
2027 Marine Le Pen montrait les mêmes
faiblesses qu'elle a montré pendant les
deux autres candidatures parce qu'elle
fait toujours moins que ce qu'on lui
attribue à l'origine les sondages sont
toujours meilleurs que son résultat
final moi je pense et puis et puis elle
porte le nom de Le Pen etc je pense que
le meilleur
possible pour remplir une défaillance de
Marine Le Pen au dernier moment serais
Jordan Bardella c'est la quatrième
candidature de Marine Le Pen en 2027
vous allez nous expliquer pourquoi vous
n'êtes pas d'accord avec Valérie non moi
je pense que en l'état ça reste un atout
et un atout de poids pour Marine Le Pen
parce qu'il y a quand même un
légitimisme qui est particulièrement
important au sein du rassemblement
national quoi qu'on en dise après que
dans le regard des observateurs on se
dise il est meilleur qu'elle
certainement en tout cas ça fait un
cadre de premier poids pour le
rassemblement national qui permet
d'occuper le terrain qui permet aussi de
faire le sale boulot dans l'ajout de
politique semaine après semaine ce qu'on
décrivait du la mise en retrait très
très confortable de Marine Le Pen et
plus largement de son groupe à
l'Assemblée il y a un discours qui est
beaucoup plus identitaire il y a un
discours qui parle à des franges plus
populaires et en même temps un des
franges beaucoup plus radicales de
l'extrême droite donc je pense que c'est
un atout dont Marine Le Pen et dont le
Front national à l'époque n'a jamais pu
disposer c'est une sorte de de Bruno
Maigret en fiable mais c'est vrai que
depuis les années il y avait en tout cas
on peut pas dire que Philippot jouait ce
rôle là donc je pense que c'est un atout
pour Marine Le Pen de pas dire je suis
seul avec personne oui c'est une
application qu'il faut finir sa phrase
pas forcément l'arrêter en plein milieu
Pascal c'est quoi la différence en
termes d'idées entre un Jordan Bardella
et Marine Le Pen si vous voulez je crois
pas qu'il faille placer ça sur le
terrain des idées partagent largement
les mêmes orientations en revanche ça
montre que le rassemblement national
contrairement à la plupart des autres
parties à su-organiser une relève
générationnelle et au travers de Jordan
Bardella vous voyez on dit et les
Français le partage à peu près dans une
proportion de 50% c'est un parti
d'extrême droite vous ne pouvez pas
accuser genre dans Bardella d'être de
l'extrême droite il n'en vient pas c'est
un enfant
issu de la banlieue
issu de l'immigration
de la jeunesse
il ne tient pas des propos d'extrême
droite on peut continuer moi je crois si
vous voulez qu'avec ce rassemblement
national il faut faire très attention il
faut essayer de comprendre ce phénomène
d'aujourd'hui mais pas avec les lunettes
d'hier si on continue à rabattre sans
cesse le Front national sur le fascisme
sur l'extrême droite on avancera pas on
sera soi-même on aura on aura une
posture avantageuse mais on ne
comprendra pas le phénomène qui passe
simplement d'ailleurs en France est en
train de déstabiliser un nombre de
démocratie en Europe et dans le monde
tout à fait impression Juliette il
serait même très dangereux pour le camp
des républicains démocrates de gauche
dont je suis il serait extrêmement
dangereux de considérer que tous les
électeurs de Marine Le Pen sont soit des
fous soit des fait chaud soit des
extrémistes pourquoi parce que ça veut
dire que vous renvoyez précisément dans
un extrait et vous ne respectez ni ne
considérer les raisons de ce vote et
donc si vous méprisez les électeurs du
rassemblement national vous ne saurez
jamais leur parler et vous donnerez à
Marine Le Pen un chèque en blanc pour la
victoire en 2025
au total en France aujourd'hui cette
semaine on a assisté à une nouvelle
séquence très compliquée pour la nups
sur fond de guerre des chefs et de
divergence tactiques sur les élections
européennes en ce moment c'est un peu
division à tous les étages écoutés
c'est eux qui m'exclu c'est eux qui
acceptent pas la différence le débat et
que on puisse au sein de la gauche
exprimer des points de vue différents
j'attends de mes amis et camarades qu'il
me respecte un petit peu il y a des
tensions mais en fait
accentuer les tensions déconstruire
c'est facile construire créer du lien
c'est plus difficile et c'est à ça qu'on
s'appelle personnellement je ne fais pas
la nupaisse parce que j'aime les autres
je ne les aime pas ah vous n'aimez pas
vos partenaires non non une écologie qui
n'est pas anticapitaliste pour moi c'est
du jardinage donc le socialisme pour les
économies
le socialisme qui ne m'est pas en cause
le capitalisme c'est mignon et le
communisme qui ne se donne pas comme
objectif une révolution socialiste au
moment de ce que c'est Jean-Luc
Mélenchon dans le texte Juliette ça va
craquer quand cette histoire cette nuit
pêche m'attendez d'abord ça n'a jamais
fonctionné vraiment c'est une espèce de
pseudo à corps électorale qui a été
destinée à sauver quelques sièges en
particulier celui d'Olivier fort
dernières élections législatives mais il
y a aucun aucune cohérence idéologique
aucune envie de travailler ensemble donc
en fait la nups c'est c'est déjà fini et
de toute façon c'était déjà mort avant
même d'avoir un être et à grandir et à
se développer donc c'est on a
aujourd'hui un Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui
évidemment a une verre extraordinaire
avec un parti la France insoumise qui ne
tient que par le talent de son orateur
mais qui sur le fond a complètement
dérivé et qui sur la forme est insultant
parce que être comme ça d'une violence
outrageante avec Fabien Roussel c'est
bien sûr je parle de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
c'est vraiment scier la moindre
possibilité d'union pour les prochaines
élections présidentielles
jonathanguer le fait que des
responsables politiques se détestent et
qui est de l'animosité entre eux
c'est-à-dire certains combats
du PS il y a quelques années pour avoir
des haines à peu près aussi recuites
avec peut-être un peu moins le courage
de le dire à visage découvert donc en
soit que dans les organisation politique
et notamment au sommet des organisations
politiques il puisse y avoir des
dissensions eux-mêmes des haines entre
certains personnages c'est une chose
après quand on regarde dans les
électorats de ces différentes formations
politiques ça vaut pour les communistes
comme pour les écolos les socialistes ou
les insoumis il se trouve que ce que la
nups a fait germer comme graine c'est
l'idée qu'il n'y avait pas de salut sans
union ça c'est quelque chose qui est
très ancré quoi que puissant dire
Jean-Luc Mélenchon quand il est un peu
entraîné par sa verve quoi qu'en disent
le Calimero Fabien Roussel qui envoie à
peu près autant de Sud quand il en a
l'occasion donc je pense qu'il y a
quelque chose qui est un petit peu
mortifère et qui est assez déprimant
pour les électeurs de gauche et de voir
des leaders je leur centre découper
alors que formellement et même au sein
du groupe à l'Assemblée nationale on le
voit en commission des finances ces
jours-ci avec des propositions fiscales
qui sont de l'ensemble de la nuque on le
voit à l'échelle locale et dans un
certain nombre de municipalités ou pour
le coup ces forces politiques
travaillent très bien ensemble l'enjeu
c'est l'obsession présidentielle
je pense que un qui n'est pas mort deux
si on regarde l'état des troupes dans
les autres parties je suis pas sûr que
la cohabitation absolument
dans mon département il y a une liste
nupette qui en fait c'est juste la
France insoumise et puis il y a une
liste avec tous les autres partis par
socialiste le Parti communiste
c'était une alliance électorale pour
éviter de perdre trop de députés ça
s'arrête là depuis le début ils sont
d'accord sur rien il y en a qui veulent
sortir de l'Europe il y en a qui veulent
y rester non mais ils sont mais ils sont
d'accord absolument sur rien depuis le
départ de cette histoire donc chacun
reprend ses biches chacun reprend son
idéologie moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est
pourquoi c'est Fabien Roussel l'homme le
plus populaire à gauche
Fabien Roussel est effectivement la
personnalité préférée des électeurs de
gauche
52% d'opinion positives ils devancent
François Ruffin Jean-Luc Mélenchon
François Hollande qui récolte tous les
trois 49%
et donc ça c'est quelque chose qui
m'intéresse parce que c'est quelqu'un
qui a fait 2 % des voix à l'élection
présidentielle Jean-Luc Mélenchon nous
l'annonçait quasiment au deuxième tour
il a pas pu y aller et tout d'un coup il
y a eu une espèce de montée en puissance
de Fabien Roussel depuis quelques mois
qui est absolument fulgurante et moi je
pense simplement que il parle comme les
gens pensent je pense en parler tout à
l'heure Juliette parlait de tous ces
territoires que la gauche a perdu au
profit du rassemblement national je
pense qu'un Fabien Roussel peut avoir le
profil pour aller les rechercher
à la classe ouvrière et parler français
vous avez vu d'ailleurs que les rapports
de force 52 49 c'est pas énorme
du moment mais ce qu'il y a de très
important à mon avis derrière cette
affaire c'est qu'est-ce que c'est que la
gauche aujourd'hui ah et là je crois que
c'est bisbille entre leader qui
s'échange avant tout des insultes
révèle en fait un profond malaise chez
les électeurs de gauche entre deux
conceptions de la gauche il y a d'un
côté en effet des gens comme Russell
Cazeneuve qui croit en effet à une
conception de la gauche républicaine
laïque et puis de l'autre côté il y a
une gauche qui a abandonné cet héritage
qui était largement les siens qui
n'étaient pas uniquement le sien mais
qui était largement le sien et qui
aujourd'hui est une gauche qui
privilégie l'approche multiculturale etc
bien donc je crois qu'il y a là de
gauche deux stratégies totalement
divergentes qui pour des raisons tout à
fait pratiquées se sont mis ensemble
dans ce qu'on appelle la nupes qui a été
présenté à tort par nombre
d'observateurs comme étant une union de
la gauche m'attendez c'est une imposture
c'est pas une union de la gauche la
nupestre c'est la mise sous tutelle de
la France insoumise des trois autres
partenaires
pas du tout il se mettait il se
présentait ensemble au premier tour et
c'était les électeurs qui décident des
électeurs ne s'y sont pas trompés
puisque aux élections législatives et
présidentielle on a bien vu que ça
n'avait pas permis à la vitesse d'avoir
une majorité écrasante donc on voit bien
que l'Union Jean-Luc Mélenchon pardon
s'il avait vraiment fait cette union de
la gauche il aurait fait un score
supérieur à celui François Hollande en
2012 et si vous faites la différence
entre le score de François Hollande de
2012 et le score de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
en 2017 et en 2022 c'est François
Hollande qui reste très au dessus et aux
prochaines élections et aux prochaines
élections européennes tous les sondages
donnent des scores plus importants avec
des candidatures séparées si vous
additionnez PS les verres etc etc vous
aurez encore plus
importantes des difficultés actuelles de
la gauche je peux même vous dire
pourquoi la gauche est morte
actuelle
elle a quitté la laïcité et là à l'heure
actuelle c'est un ministre dit de droite
ou assimilé de droite qui dit la Baya il
en faut pas l'école et il a raison il a
tout à fait raison
j'étais parti de gauche qui disent ah
non il faut laisser un vêtement lui mais
ce qui a porté notamment l'un des le
gros bataillon du Parti socialiste
c'était les enseignants pourquoi pour la
laïcité
qui est aujourd'hui à gauche les
problèmes à gauche c'est aussi dû à
cette différence de conception sur la
laïcité Jonathan
est libre de diffuser qui veut moi j'ai
pas spécialement envie de réagir sur
Patrick pelouse sur des sur des
questions
donc qu'il y ait des enfin je rappelle
que dans le gouvernement de François
Hollande il y avait Manuel Valls et
Benoît Hamon donc il y avait des
cohabitations aussi de conception
historiquement et Arnaud monte c'est
encore autre chose il y a des
conceptions c'est pas nouveau c'est pas
la Nupe qui vient révéler des
conceptions différentes c'est de
l'acuité des questions identitaires dans
le débat public qui fait que ça devient
un sujet majeur quand vous rassemblez
dans le même bloc moi ça me fait
toujours sourire Fabien Roussel et
Bernard Cazeneuve moi je savais pas que
Bernard Cazeneuve partager comme Fabien
Roussel l'envie de mettre à balle
capitalisme je pense ça reste quelque
chose entre le réformiste il a envie de
le réformer Bernard Cazeneuve
tellement partie de son identité
politique et en tout cas il y a rien de
commun avec Fabien Roussel et les
troupes communistes sur ces questions là
honnêtement moi je pense qu'il pas de
question identitaire à cette question
laïque qui peut être un sujet il y a
aussi quand même toutes les questions
sociales et la radicalité de la
transformation sur les questions
écologiques sur les questions de partage
de la richesse sur les questions
fiscalité est-ce que vous nous dites il
y a pas tellement de divergences et là
vous nous dites il y a plein de
divergences
des proculés
les faiblesses de la gauche aujourd'hui
c'est moins l'incapacité de ces
représentants à 100 ans que l'incapacité
à faire d'abord une autocritique claire
sur les raisons de l'échec de la gauche
de gouvernement de ces 10 dernières
années il y a eu du bon il y a eu du
mauvais mais ce serait bien d'avoir une
appréciation objective et deuxièmement
c'est l'incapacité à penser à un projet
d'avenir à l'aune du gigantesque tsunami
qui est le le bouleversement climatique
et là on a aucun discours aujourd'hui de
gauche qui est capable de résoudre et
d'adresser la problématique identitaire
et la question du nouveau modèle
économique pour survivre sur cette
planète
je voudrais je voudrais rebondir sur ce
qu'a dit Jonathan quand même il y a
quand même quelque chose de nouveau dans
la nupestre c'est que c'est LFI qui est
largement majoritaire dans l'ancienne
gauche dont vous parlez avec les
ministres différents de sensibilité
différente il y avait pas de la fille et
mon ami c'est la finance au Bourget
c'était fait pour bloquer Jean-Luc
Mélenchon le rôle de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
aujourd'hui dans la gauche n'est
absolument pas ce qu'il était autrefois
merci général Revol à Nicolas Sarkozy
l'ancien chef de l'État est en pleine
promotion pour les derniers tome de ses
mémoires mais il a pris le temps cette
semaine de déjeuner avec les députés LR
discussion à battre son rompu il a parlé
de tout et notamment revenu sur son
rapport à Emmanuel Macron il dit la
chose suivante Macron c'est fini c'est
le seul Français qui ne pourra pas se
présenter à la prochaine présidentielle
vous devez jouer le rapport de force et
le forcer à faire une politique de
droite ce qui n'est pas naturel chez lui
fin de citation les députés de droite
ont manifest ont été ravi et
impressionné par ses échanges avec
Nicolas Sarkozy Pascal ça pèse encore
Nicolas Sarkozy à droite il a encore une
voix qui porte faut pas mélanger deux
choses si vous voulez là on parle depuis
bientôt une heure de politique et puis
là on parle essentiellement d'une
promotion d'un livre d'une opération de
marketing et donc Nicolas Sarkozy est
dans la promotion du tome 3 que je vais
découvrir avec beaucoup d'intérêt du
tome 3 de ses mémoires et je crois que
on mélange un peu les deux parce que sur
le terrain politique si vous voulez
Nicolas Sarkozy n'est plus j'allais dire
la référence centrale des députés des
élus de droite qu'il pouvait être encore
il y a deux ans et plus Nicolas Sarkozy
continuera à pratiquer ce qu'il aime
beaucoup les petits mots Vengeurs
balancés en particulier
essentiellement les siens plus le déclin
de l'étoile présidentielle sera formé il
cherche quelque chose politiquement et
cherche à peser il cherche de
l'influence ce qui est très intéressant
quand vous lisez ou parcourez le temps
des combats parce que c'est très long
c'est qu'il ne parle que de lui en fait
c'est à dire il se met en scène il
raconte sa propre histoire il raconte
son bien-être il n'y a pas il n'y a
aucune vision politique il n'y a aucune
proposition d'un avenir à la France il
n'y a aucun soutien à personne il n'y a
que son avis de Nicolas Sarkozy sur lui
et les autres donc ça va tout à fait
dans le sens
ça va tout à fait dans le sens de ce que
devient de dire parce qu'elle Perrino
c'est à dire qu'il n'a pas de il n'a pas
d'influence politique dans le jeu
politique français il n'a pas
d'influence politique il joue sa propre
partition celle d'un ancien président
qui reste de l'énergie et qui veut faire
connaître et pourtant Jonathan il va
quand même rencontrer les députés LR il
essaye voilà de nouer des contacts des
liens qu'est-ce qu'ils recherchent
vraiment il y a comme une ambition
politique derrière
il y a un sujet plutôt de
psychanalytique de ne pas être avoir été
ne pas mourir être si jeune avoir été si
haut et puis quand même ça va se poser
avec encore plus d'acuités pour Emmanuel
Macron mais comment continuer à exister
alors que on ne sera plus jamais
président de la République je rappelle
qu'il a tenté un retour Nicolas Sarkozy
qu'il a été balayé à la primaire de DLR
à l'époque donc cette histoire d'une
certaine manière elle est soldée après
il pense qu'il peut jouer un rôle dans
cette espèce de Gobi twin ou de pas de 2
un peu fantasmé entre LR et la majorité
actuelle au dernière élections
législatives il est essentiel ça
brouissait apporter quelques dizaines de
responsables de droite qui devaient
basculer pour Emmanuel Macron on les
attend toujours il y en a eu aucun donc
un son poids il est un peu limité c'est
un peu comme quand on va voir un vieil
ancien qui a une existence médiatique et
une espèce de de surface un peu people
quand même aujourd'hui c'est un
personnage il y en a pas tant que ça
dans la vie politique française des
anciens présidents comment plus il est
assez prolixe et je j'aimais bien le
lapsus de de Pascal Perrineau sur
Sarkozy je pense que c'est ça c'est les
causeries de Nicolas Sarkozy et pas
personne
président de la République donc moi
j'aime bien qu'on respecte les anciens
présidents de la République et pas
forcément
voilà et Nicolas Sarkozy aussi voilà
deuxièmement je trouve qu'on est dans un
moment politique ou beaucoup se
cherchent sur toi droite un chef et une
référence et on peut pas dire qu'à
droite il y a un leader incontesté et
incontestable qui se soit imposé et donc
tout naturellement les yeux se tournent
vers Nicolas Sarkozy qui aurait bien
tort de pas croire en l'hypothèse de son
de retour ou de son destin quand on voit
la Bérézina actuelle et la menace que le
parti de Marine Le Pen fait peser sur la
France je rappelle quand même et Dieu
sait si je l'ai combattu à l'époque en
2007 puisque je saute mais c'est Golan
royal mais enfin il a quand même réussi
à faire le à faire grâce à sa campagne à
lui à faire faire le plus petit score au
rassemblement national de ces 25
dernières années donc vous croyez
d'autres moi personnellement je n'y
crois pas du tout mais moi mon avis tout
le monde s'en fiche ce qui est
intéressant c'est de voir qu'il a quand
même du succès son livre se vend et et
d'ailleurs ça fait 10 minutes qu'on en
parle alors écoutez-le
notamment sur les sujets internationaux
et il prend un peu une position
différente de celle d'Emmanuel Macron
notamment en ce qui concerne Vladimir
Poutine
ces chars étaient à 25 km de BBC je suis
parti à Moscou on a discuté 7h30
et la guerre s'est arrêtée il s'est
retiré de Géorgie et aujourd'hui la
Géorgie est un pays libre je dis pas que
on peut refaire ce que j'ai fait sans
doute vous avez raison les circonstances
sont différentes Pascal il parle encore
un peu lui et pas seulement il parle
aussi d'Emmanuel Macron oui oui il parle
beaucoup de lui il parle en effet de la
fréquentation des puissants et le fait
que à l'époque où il était puissant
cette coalition des puissants décidèrent
de la fin de telle ou telle guerre avec
lui c'était mieux avec lui je veux dire
il y a là un égotisme en effet tout à
fait impressionnant c'est pas le seul
dans la classe politique à être
fortement touché par cette égotisme mais
je veux dire l'égotisme il faut qu'il
s'inscrivent dans un projet collectif et
le gros problème aujourd'hui c'est que
les égaux qui ont toujours existé
s'inscrivent de moins en moins dans des
projets politiques mobilisateurs c'est
ça la crise de la politique vous parlez
d'égotisme et on parlait des anciens qui
veulent souvent revenir comme achat à
chaque intervention ou presque Nicolas
Sarkozy a tenu à rendre hommage à son
ami François Hollande mardi il aurait
déclaré devant les députés air la chose
suivante ce n'est pas que je le hais
mais je le méprise encore une fois
Jonathan pourquoi tant de haine entre
ces deux personnages notre vie publique
je pense qu'il y a moins d'obsessions de
Nicolas Sarkozy dans l'esprit de
François Hollande que de que dacrymonie
dans l'esprit de Sarkozy Sarkozy a été
battu par François Hollande c'est quand
même une vraie différence il considère
que c'est une anomalie l'histoire
d'avoir été battue il a quand même passé
toute la fin de toute l'après élection
de François Hollande a expliqué qu'avec
deux semaines de campagnes en plus il
aurait gagné donc quelque chose qui n'a
jamais digéré ça limite c'est son
histoire moi j'ai pas envie de me de
rentrer dans la psyché de Nicolas
Sarkozy sur pourquoi il arrive pas 12
ans après à accepter que les Français
lui aient dit non comme je le disais il
a eu l'occasion de se représenter devant
les électeurs de droite on lui a encore
dit non donc au bout d'un moment il faut
peut-être s'interroger non je pense
qu'il y a après il y a évidemment que
c'est des c'était ça a été des
adversaires politiques il y a je pense
oui mais
assez honnête Nicolas Sarkozy dans ce
qu'il dit je pense effectivement il
méprise François Hollande ça n'empêche
que François Hollande l'abattu à un
moment où il s'y attendait pas donc
c'est la trace que l'estra Nicolas
Sarkozy dans l'histoire honnêtement moi
je tout à fait pour avoir du respect
pour la fonction et avoir du respect
pour les anciens présidents après ça se
mérite aussi un petit peu c'est à dire
qu'on doit les valeurs morales et le
parcours judiciaire de Nicolas Sarkozy
ces dernières années je pense que ça
restera d'abord comme le premier
président à avoir eu autant d'affaires à
régler sur le plan judiciaire une fois
sa sortie de l'Elysée et quand il prend
la parole sur les questions étrangères
et qu'en gros le seul impact que ça
c'est que la propagande du Kremlin avec
Vladimir Poutine puisse faire savoir
qu'il est tout à fait d'accord avec
Nicolas Sarkozy ça ne grandit pas la
fonction présidentielle à ce titre là je
préfère ce que disait à l'un Juppé à
l'époque est-ce que dit Alain Juppé
aujourd'hui très rapidement Juliette
c'est impossible de décrocher quand on a
été aussi haut quand on voit François
Hollande Nicolas Sarkozy revenir sur les
plateaux faire des interventions oui
c'est impossible parce que ils ont été
habités d'abord toute leur vie par
l'élection puis ils ont eu le pouvoir
suprême si je puis dire et donc dans une
cinquième République qui donne toujours
plus de pouvoir à sa représentation
ultime évidemment que c'est pas possible
d'arrêter comme chaque semaine les amis
on termine par un top flop je vous pose
une question très simple qui a marqué
l'actualité de la semaine en bien ou en
mal cher Pascal vous commencez qui est
votre top de la semaine on top comme
souvent c'est Claude malurey j'adore
cette politique
j'adore sa subtilité j'aime beaucoup son
art oratoire et le diagnostic qu'il a
porté sur la nupes je le cite elle était
en soins palliatif depuis le mois de
juin elle est aujourd'hui au stade du
don d'organe je crois que c'est marqué
au coin du bon sens votre flop Pascal
mon flop c'est Sophie chikiru député de
la France insoumise en effet qui a tout
de même dérapé alors une fois de plus
mais ce qui est inquiétant c'est que le
dérapage de ces filles shikiru qui il y
a du dos pardon il y a du Doriot
d'enroussel je veux dire ou bien elle
connaît pas Doriot ou bien elle connaît
pas Roussel mais enfin c'est vraiment le
grand n'importe quoi mais ce qui était
très inquiétant c'est que c'est approuvé
par Jean-Luc Mélenchon et ça ça donne
une idée de la dérive politique et
idéologique du patron de la France
insoumise Valérie même question votre
top votre flop de la semaine mais
écoutez moi j'ai deux tops en fait le
premier c'est la visite du pape à
Marseille et bien à Marseille est pas en
France pourquoi Marseille parce que
Marseille c'est la Méditerranée et que
c'est le grand cimetière des migrants
comme il l'a appelé je trouve que ce
pape qui vient faire cette visite dans
cette ville c'est très hautement
symbolique et ça porte beaucoup de
valeur qui sont qui sont positives notre
deuxième top le deuxième top c'est le
fait que le Parti socialiste est refusé
de s'associer à la manifestation contre
les violences policières je trouve que
enfin ils reprennent leur position
naturelle et c'est peut-être la fin de
la Grande soumission du PS à la France
insoumise et je ne ferai suivre qu'en
être content Jonathan votre top votre
flop de la semaine alors moi j'ai du mal
à trouver chez des politiques donc je
suis allé voir un peu ailleurs mon top
c'est Emmanuel Béart
je le courage de prendre la parole sur
la question de l'inceste des d'évoquer
je pense une réalité qui est un déni
sociétal persistant la co-réalisé un
documentaire dans lequel à la base elle
était censée donner la parole à quatre
victimes et où finalement elle a pris la
responsabilité fait le choix de raconter
les les violences et les les abus dont
elle a été victime adolescente donc
j'invite même si c'est pas sur Public
Sénat entre les résultats des élections
sénatoriales dimanche à regarder le
documentaire qui est diffusé par M6 et
juste un tout petit tout petit alerte
sur la civisme donc la commission qui
avait été créée il y a deux ans qui ont
aujourd'hui le sort est menacé et qui a
fait un travail assez remarquable de
pour récolter cette parole
le flop ça va être encore plus long non
c'est sûr c'est un flop sur l'état
français en sur les menaces sur la
liberté d'informer en deux mots les 39
heures de garde à vue de la journaliste
de disclose pour en gros lui exhorter
lui extirper plutôt ses sources et de
l'autre les trois journalistes de Libé
qui ont été convoqués pareil par la
police hier à Lille encore une fois pour
mettre la pression sur quelque chose que
le gouvernement défend des qu'il en a
l'occasion mais qu'il piétine largement
Juliette la liberté d'informer c'est
important l'égalité femme homme et le
manque de volonté du gouvernement
français sur ce sujet là avec deux
exemples nets premier exemple la Cour
des comptes vient de rendre un rapport
sur l'égalité femme homme qui montre que
même le comité interministériel de lutte
contre les inégalités femmes hommes qui
auraient dû être un signal politique n'a
jamais été réuni deuxièmement il y a une
loi en ce moment qui est en discussion à
Bruxelles pour lutter contre les
violences conjugales et la France et
l'un des rares pays à avoir refusé
d'inscrire le viol dans le cadre de
cette loi double c'est un double flop et
un dernier sur le glyphosate pourquoi la
Commission européenne vient d'accorder
10 ans de plus pour exploiter cette
herbicide dangereux je me le demande
trois flops c'est la première fois qu'on
fait ça merci Juliette merci à tous les
quatre c'est la fin de cette émission
merci d'y avoir participé salut à vous
derrière votre écran on me dit dans
l'oreillette que vous êtes encore plus
nombreux que la saison dernière merci
merci infiniment continuer à nous suivre
vous pouvez nous retrouver en replay et
en podcast sur notre plateforme public
sénat.fr et nous on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine et même jour même
heure et même endroit bye bye
[Musique]